hello everyone and welcome to the last
day of the world blitz championship
today I started a bit late we had some
guests but I hope you don't mind rather
than showing you a game by Carlson or
someone from the boards they usually
show I decided to show you a game by one
and only ukrainian grandmaster anton
Korra both he was a two-time ukrainian
champion and his games are always
extremely interesting I remember this
one game in particular from last year's
World Rally Championship played in Doha
Qatar he played this amazing King Hunt I
can't really pinpoint which game it was
if any of you know this game do share in
the comments I will pin point to pin
your comment so everyone can enjoy this
game but for this game its bori stuff
chenko with the white pieces and anton
core above with the black pieces this is
round 12 of the world blitz championship
and for those of you who played the
Sicilian I'm sure this game will be
quite a treat so let's see this game
subchapter Savchenko opens would eat
four and we have c5 this is still in
defense by Antonio robot Knight to f3 d6
d4 C captures Knight captures and Knight
to f6
we have Knight to c3 and a6 core above
goes for the knight or variation Bishop
to g5 we have e 6f 4 and Queen to c7
still all standard theory of the knight
of variation Queen to f3 Knight to c6
and here White has a couple of good
options
Savchenko could go for a queenside
castle here he could capture on f6 for
example he could capture on c6
but here he plays Knight d2 e - probably
a prepared variation for a blitz game it
doesn't really doesn't really make sense
giving black this this much blocking
your own pieces and ok you do avoid the
exchange of pieces but Anton Corriveau
doesn't seem to have a problem with this
he plays simply continues developing
Bishop to e7
Savchenko castles and b5 now and already
Black has started his Queen side
expansion and when you have opposite
opposite sides castles the player who
starts his attack
on the side that he wants to attack
first I will usually get there first so
we have e 5d captors on e5 f captures on
e5 and now Knight to d5
we have Bishop captures on e7 night
captain ID captures on e7 and Knight to
f4 and here there are a lot of options
if Cora ball was playing a classical
game probably he would have gone for
something like rook to b8 followed by a
5 and B 4 or maybe even rook to b8 and
immediately before but what's the idea
behind the pawn here can the pawn on e5
be captured you can capture a good
tonight because you're rockin e8 is
hanging but actually capturing go to put
the Queen it's perfectly fine for black
but after Bishop d3 you don't really
want to grab a pawn in a blitz game and
allow your opponent to continue
developing so after Knight to f4 and
encore both completely ignores this and
he castles himself
we have rook to e1 Bishop to b7 and now
Bishop to d3 and again what's the idea
here why not capture this juicy e5 pawn
well if Knight captures then you allow
Bishop captures on h7 King captures
Queen to h5 check and after King goes
back you can simply recapture the piece
with the rook and or with the Queen and
while this is still perfectly fine for
black there's no reason to allow this in
a blitz game and Anton Corbijn totally
ignores this after Bishop d3
he's not interested in d5 pawn he plays
b4 continues his own plan on the Queen
side Queen to h3 and in between move by
self chenko threatening checkmate on a7
chord off stops this h6 we have Knight
to e4 now and it seems like White has
started some sort of an attack of its
own but Cora buff sees right through
this and he simply now captures the e5
pawn which is the best move definitely
in the position seems to be one getting
the King out of that nasty C file the
queen is on the C file the rook is
quickly coming to c8 and this leaves the
opportunity of rook to c1 protecting the
C to pawn but Cora both immediately
captures the bishop on d3 we have Knight
captures on d3 and now rook a to c8 and
our white the
natalie has some issues here there's
really no clear way to protect the c2
pawn rook to see one now isn't really
possible because your knight is hanging
on e4
so here probably Knight eat the c5 would
be the best move kind of blocking it but
then your night is just stranded there
after this rook e8 the CA tonight
capture some before it was played
now the c2 point is protected but this
is only temporary core above removes the
night playing a5 of course Knight goes
to d3 and now comes Queen captures and
c2 this comes with Czech king - I want
and now Bishop captures on e4 rod
captures on e4 and rock - the rock after
d8 attacking the knight and d3 twice and
there is no way to protect this night
this is game over for white if you try
something like road to e3 to add an
additional protector of the night on d3
simply rook captures on d3 wins the game
immediately if you recapture a queen to
c1 this leads to checkmate rod captures
rook captures on c1 this is checkmate so
I have to look after the eight White had
to try something it's a blitz game a3
was played but now comes to row captures
on d3 this comes with a temp on the
Queen and h3 Queen to g4 and queen to g4
doesn't really count with any threat
whatsoever
you could simply play f5 this is
perfectly fine for black a lot of moves
are fine here for black but aunt encore
above as usually he always plays the
most interesting move he plays rook to
b8 he threatens checkmate on b2 rook to
be one defending and now the instant
finisher rook captures on a3 and in this
position Russian Grandmaster Boris
Savchenko resigned at the game the King
has no squares only move here is B
captures on a3 and here either Queen
captures row can be won or rocket Rizzo
can be one will be checkmate for example
rook captures and the King has nowhere
to go
a beautiful checkmate and one one in a
series of beautiful games by ukrainian
grandmaster anton core above so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I will
cover some more games from the world
will its championship of course
and I would like to thank a lot of you I
would like to thank Gregory Harvest get
us some chocolate Demetriou Michael
Gorton William Avery and Jonathan Davies
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it and
Jonathan Davies here made a ridiculously
large contribution to my channel this is
for someone running a chess channel this
is just a ridiculous contribution so
thank you a lot sir
you know I really don't know what to say
I I feel like a void boy only a couple
of only several divisions lower this is
quite unimaginable but thank you sir and
thank you everyone so yeah that's the
game as usual you can check to my
previous videos here both of them will
be from the world widths and wrap a
championship or wrap it I'll still have
to see which one I put and I haven't had
the time to check a lot of the games I
did find this game by anton core above
and I always enjoy games by Anton gorev
of but feel free to suggest any games
that you yourself found interesting use
the hashtag suggestion and I will make
sure to go through all the comments so
that's it thank you all for watching and
I will see you soon